- Five.
"Three. Two. One. Pull up."
- I'm experiencing 1.8gs
right now, which means I weigh
about 1.8 times what I normally would.
I've been instructed to keep my head
front and centre to avoid nausea.
But all this is about to change
because this is the
European Space Agency's zero-g flight.
Those are students doing research.
This is Neil, who's here for my safety.
And we're about to go into freefall.
Whoa!
And here's the confusing thing.
We are still going up right now.
That camera is stabilised to
the actual horizon,
and it's not until 10 seconds into
our 20 second parabola,
into our manoeuvre, that we
clip the apex and start heading
back down towards the ground.
And here we go, 1.8gs.
- In this special aircraft,
we divide the three axes.
There is pitch, roll and thrust,
and each pilot flies one axis.
In every other aircraft, one pilot
flies the three axes and
the other one manages the systems,
talks on the radio, and so on.
To fly parabolas, we need to
fly only one axis by one pilot.
We try to avoid any turbulence.
Any turbulence is a nightmare for us.
- The two control sticks,
just like any plane,
are completely locked together,
so they always move at the same time.
So one of the pilots is using
effectively elastic bands
on either side of his stick
so that he doesn't affect
the axis of the other pilot.
One of them does the pitch,
the other one does the roll
whilst trying not to upset the pitch.
- In 1971, the Apollo 15 astronauts
tested something on the moon:
The idea that all objects,
no matter their weight,
fall at the same speed
if there's no air.
They used a hammer and a feather,
and they landed at the same time.
ASTRONAUT: "How about that?"
- But the weirdest thing is that
if that astronaut had thrown that hammer,
it still would have been in free fall
from the moment it left his glove
to the moment it hit the ground.
The only pull on it is from
the gravity of the moon.
The maths work out the same
no matter what speed or direction
it's going relative to us.
That's what we just did here.
If it sounds weird, sure,
but we just proved it.
And we're about to prove it again.
- Every five parabolas
or ten parabolas, we change
to maintain the best accuracy
of the parabolas, especially
on the pitch axis because
it's the most demanding flying technique.
So after five or ten parabolas,
you are so tired and you
have to go on to another
less demanding axis.
PILOT: "3, 2, 1, pull up."
- This parabolic manoeuvre
isn't the normal kind of thing
that you do in an Airbus, and
the software in this plane
hasn't been modified because to do so
would be a huge effort to re-qualify it.
With the normal software,
you have the normal alarm
saying, "This doesn't seem
like a very good idea, guys,"
and one of the pilots that
isn't too busy on the other two axes
is turning off the alarms
that we don't need to worry about
and keeping track of the ones
we might need to worry about.
PILOT: "Injection."
- So those pilots are
keeping us on the exact path
that an object would take
if you hurled it into the sky
at hundreds of kilometres per hour
and there was no air.
They're giving us this little protective bubble
of zero-g to fly around in.
There is no terminal velocity here,
only the design limitations of the plane.
And we're going to hit those pretty
soon, along with something else.
Because when you're descending
this fast towards the ground,
the Earth approaches pretty quickly.
Thank you, Neil!
If you're a Masters or PhD
student from an ESA member state,
and you want to be
one of the people back there,
then have a look at the
Fly Your Thesis program.
The link is in the description.
Thank you, Neil!
I got it, I got it, we're good.
And down.
Oooph.